hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast on
Monday October 8 2018 what's going on
how are ya how's it going I am uh I am
good how are you oh my god that is great
can barely hear myself I'm out here on
the road I don't have all my podcasting
equipment Oh bill you're really gonna
come up with the excuses on Monday
morning maybe I yeah I'm still here in
Boston after a whirlwind tour of the New
England states
Springfield Boston and then Bridgeport
Connecticut I want to thank everybody
that came out you know an incredible
weekend most people I've ever performed
to over a three-day period in my career
and could not have gone any better
thank you so very much I was in I did
the Boston Garden to TD Banknorth Garden
on Friday night in the round got
together with some buddies of mine I
used to jam with back in the day and we
played in the empty arena just had the
best time ever right so anyways you know
I walk in it's [ __ ] place is huge
it's like Jesus Christ so you know you
make a little bit of noise in there so
it's not as nerve-racking
then you calm down a little bit you get
comfortable and then all of a sudden the
people start coming and it fills up and
then you get nervous again right so I
had Tony v the great Tony beat the guy
who taught me basically how to write by
not writing first guy I met who didn't
write [ __ ] down and I was like what if
you forget a joke and he was just like
well it means it's time to stop doing it
I just thought it was such a [ __ ]
bad-ass cavalier attitude was like I
want to be like that guy so anyways I
worked with him and Paul virzi so they
both go up and they just acting like
they're just doing a regular spot and if
they're [ __ ] murdering both of them
murdering you know first he was stuck in
traffic he I think he had a double Park
or something
before he went in there so I don't think
he had time to be nervous he just ran
out and did it so anyways I'm in the
they put you for the green room when you
did it we were in the referee's like a
little [ __ ] pretty called locker room
now I was thinking just all the people
that must have been screaming on the
other side of the door because you're
not allowed to go in there if you're a
coach player or anything like that
so anyways I'm sitting in there doing
what you do in that moment thinking how
the [ __ ] did I get here
why me is this the end is everybody
gonna show it'd be like you know we
don't think he's funny anymore right so
I'm going through all of this [ __ ]
trying to talk myself off the ledge so I
could just go out there and act like
this big deal is not a big deal so I can
perform the best and right before I go
out there my cell phone rings and I see
it's it's my wife and I'm like ah look
at this perfect timing this is why I
love her this is why she's the best
she's you know she's gonna say hey don't
be nervous
go out there you earned it I love you
blah blah all that [ __ ] right
well I pick up my phone in my laughs
she's crying hysterically and um my
first thought was something happened to
our kid like oh my god did she fall down
did you drop her did somebody come into
the house I what the [ __ ] happened like
I picked up the phone she's like they
like looks like what well what's the
matter what's the matter like what
what's the matter she's like nothing bad
Michael what is it she's like I just saw
a star is born and it was so good I was
like oh you [ __ ] kidding I was like
honey I got a show I got to go do all
right I thought the [ __ ] [ __ ] that
went through my head all Stephen King
level stuff of what could have been
happened to her in the house and my
daughter and all of that type of stuff
so
was so [ __ ] ridiculous it just made
me laugh and I went out there and I just
told the story and then I was kind of
fine for the rest of the show but um it
was uh I don't know
these past two weekends it felt like I
dreamed the show so it didn't feel like
they really happened so I don't know how
to hell I got to that to be able to be
the guy that did it but I just want to
thank everybody for coming out and I the
Boston Garden one really freaked me out
because I I literally started my
stand-up career I told my first [ __ ] and
dick jokes literally at Nick's comedy
stop I mean I could have walked over
there they would have taken me about
twenty five minutes but still I could
still walk van stage said I'm in so
anyways I went out there and I had a
great time the only thing I had to deal
with it was in the round those the stool
was in the middle and I had to keep
walking around either side of it and
I've learned what you want what you want
to do is just take the stool out of the
middle and just lay it down on its side
you know then if you want to sit down
just pick it up and sit down I guess if
you were gonna do that but I just feel
like if it's in the round you have to
kind of be moving so people aren't
staring at your backside the whole time
anyways and then I got on the other side
of that one and that one was
nerve-racking just because I had all
kinds of family and friends and
co-workers and people I went to school
with all of those people coming down and
it's just like boy what if I have a
whole sticker room tonight what if I
have a bad one then they got to be like
no it was good it was good
God did you uh you lost a little weight
you look good you going to the gym
people trying to change the subject I
like that shirt your shirt looked great
things you don't want to hear after a
set um so anyway so now I'm on the other
side of it and the Red Sox played Game
one and of course it was a nail-biter
and I was just thinking man if we don't
win the Chris Sale game we're [ __ ] and
we want it so thank God so then Game two
comes around the next night and I am in
Bridgeport
Connecticut and I missed the whole game
because I was traveling and then I was
also doing my show and once again
unfortunately price could not get us a
victory in the postseason and then of
course now it's like all the wheels are
coming out embossed everybody's just
like oh my god how could we have played
two games with the New York Yankees and
we won one and they won one who ever saw
that coming after a hundred and eight
regular season wins season she's [ __ ]
people it's just like what happened like
they were like already writing in the
globe going was the hundred and eight
win season just a mirage because we lost
one [ __ ] game to a two hundred
million dollar team that won a hundred
games that we played 19 times this year
we went ten and nine we won one they won
one we won too they won one we won one
they won three we swept them and then
they went 2 and 1/2 and won against us
and then yeah I had um I had a hundred
bucks on each game but in 50 with virzi
and fifty with my agent you know the
overall season thing the most I got up
they were up by like 150 at one point
then I was up 150 and then in the end 19
games they owed me 50 bucks each we
wanted one more [ __ ] game so
everybody's sitting there freaking the
[ __ ] out and they're gonna try to build
this thing up like oh my god this is the
greatest team one of the greatest teams
ever to have won 108 [ __ ] games it
doesn't mean [ __ ] the Orioles are not
gonna be there in October I keep saying
how many times do I have to be right how
many times do you guys have to shake
your head and discuss and reach for the
stop button because once again Oh ball
Billy old freckles himself is once again
crowing about something that he said was
going to happen I would say as far back
as July you know definitely after we
slept him in August I was like what
exactly like an ESPN oh my god it's
[ __ ] over it's over
it isn't over so for all you people out
there who get confused with regular
season wins okay just take everybody off
the board at the end of the season who
isn't going to go into the playoffs and
then look how they did against the
playoff teams it's as simple as that I
think we were about you know pretty even
with the Indians I didn't look up the
Indians or the Astros but I think we're
even with the Indians we probably had a
losing record against the Astros and
went ten and nine against the Yankees so
those are the teams were going to be
playing that's how they've matched up
against us why is it surprising that
we're 1 and 1 if we lose this playoff
series yeah it won't be near nearly as a
surprising [ __ ] thing you know
considering the last two times we played
the Yankees we've lost both regular
season series right so I'd say we're due
to win this one so we need old [ __ ]
whatever his [ __ ] name is priscila to
have one of his good games tonight then
we'll be up two games to one before we
get the [ __ ] kicked out of us by the
Astros that's my prediction
that's what I feel is going to happen if
we get by the Yankees and if we don't
get by the Yankees despite what
Shaughnessy and all these guys will say
it wasn't a major [ __ ] collapse
despite what Johnny Damon said I guess
one of my buddies goes dude you believe
Johnny Damon his [ __ ] uh rooting for
the Yankees it's like yeah absolutely I
can absolutely he wasn't a red sock he
was an a and then he became a free agent
and once she once you get a [ __ ] free
agent you can't fall in love with them
it's like falling in love with a
stripper all right he's gonna go with
the money he didn't give a [ __ ] pay me
he grew his [ __ ] out you know things at
the Red Sox and then he goes to the
Yankees yeah you can sign with this but
you got to get a haircut he's like okay
kid he went down there like look like a
good little schoolboy I got him all
ready for his scouting picture so now he
sees for the Yankees who gives a [ __ ]
he helped [ __ ] and the curse here at
Boston I'm good with the guy we had a
great time
we had a great [ __ ] time while he was
on the team so anyways I'm gonna watch
that game tonight
I believe game 3 is tonight and I'm not
gonna think that you know I'm hoping
that we [ __ ] win this thing but like
just a way that they're already building
this thing up like this is gonna be oh
my god
like if the Red Sox win it all this year
right is this one of the greatest teams
of all time no I wouldn't say that even
if they had 108 wins you know compared
to some of those other I look [ __ ] I
may be old force Red Sox could beat the
[ __ ] 2018 who's in waters was the old
14 one of the greatest teams of all time
I don't think so well who do you think
is one the Gracie the [ __ ] Oakland
A's in the early 70s those teams the Big
Red Machine I think those little better
teams I have no [ __ ] idea
I'm just saying everybody [ __ ] relax
put your [ __ ] eyebrows down anyways
plowing ahead here so I'm still here in
Boston and any time I come back I'm like
aha man I miss living here but this time
more so than any other time I don't know
why I just I took a like the day after
the Boston Garden cake I was you know
still staying in Boston and I walked
over to the North End as I always do and
I went down Hanover Street and then I
kind of you know I was walkabout halfway
down get better like the corner store
and then I [ __ ] break off to the left
and I try to find [ __ ] that isn't you
know Hanover Street just like the Times
Square the North End right and ended up
finding this great place to get a saying
glitch and me and my tour manager just
[ __ ] hung out in this park eat and
the sandwiches on like a perfect day
perfect sunny New England day in the
North End it was a great Italian deli
where they had all of this
just you know Italians it's just like
they take food to the entirely next
level and I was in there just like
wanting to order everything because I
live on the west coast you can't get
good Italian you can't get good pizza
you can't get any of that [ __ ]
but I was just like all right I got stay
on my diet and not get too crazy Marty
bread here so like I just got a tuna
small tuna sub I guess you'd call it out
here and just the way they season it was
[ __ ] perfect
they'd celery onions in there and
something else mixed in with the tuna
just a hint of mayonnaise and even the
size of the way they chopped up the
onions and celery it was perfect it all
just added to it and all just kept
taking the tuna to the next level and I
was sitting in the park and I was saying
to my manager so this [ __ ] sandwich
is unbelievable and he even lives on the
East Coast he's like yeah it is this is
a good sandwich
we set that going is there anything
better than just sitting out dying a
good [ __ ] sandwich and that's the end
of the sandwich story it was it was
tremendous [ __ ] tremendous that's one
of my favorite parts uh you know of
Boston and then I always walked then I
walked over to the to the garden to buy
some Bruins stuff for my daughter and I
walked by - did you know that bridge you
go over to get into Charlestown which I
never even knew that that's what that
was I'd always heard of Charlestown but
I didn't know where the [ __ ] it was
until that movie the town came out you
know I learned more goddamn [ __ ] about
Boston by watching movies about it
when I lived here I just I didn't know
you know I knew how to get to like the
sports venues but I didn't know you know
East Boston I still don't even know
where that is I wouldn't know how to get
to I know what Chelsea is I don't know
what and now I know what chows down is
back Bay I don't I don't even know where
the [ __ ] that is where that starts aware
that ends I know where Newbury Street is
and so Micra stomachs growling here
I don't know so tonight is my sort of uh
the next couple days of my hang back
here just cuz you know I got a bunch of
[ __ ] nieces and nephews and all of
that [ __ ] and I'm on the other side I
got one more arena gig everybody one
more left before [ __ ] freckles turns
back into a pumpkin and that's November
7th Madison Square Garden and it's going
to be me virzi and Joe bartnick and I'll
tell you I wish I was taping a special
right now because I feel like my hour is
ready to go but do two different things
that's I don't think I'm gonna tape
until next year but um I've been having
a more goddamn fun and I swear to God I
really believe that the more things get
crazy on social media with these
lunatics that have gone so far left that
I'm questioning whether I'm even left
anymore
the more they do that I feel like the
more you can get away with on stage
people are just laughing even more
[Music]
anyways you see that Cavanaugh guy got
on the [ __ ] Supreme Court I don't
know what that means I know a lot of
people are upset about it you know I
don't understand those women getting
[ __ ] arrested and then they're
sticking their fists in the air they're
doing the black power thing that was
black power right he [ __ ] taken that
it's hilarious
white women the United States of America
fight the power they can't they can't
come up with their own [ __ ] thing
they should steal this Sammy Hagar thing
that he used to do where he took the two
I love these things together and then he
would sort of put his index fingers
together his thumbs together and then
you know stick his tongue through the
middle and wiggle it acting like he was
going down on a woman I mean that's what
she could do in the eighties that a
mainstream concert women should have
something like that just don't stick the
tongue through it then I think it's
respect to older women I think that
that's where that part goes off
the rail I'm not sure I'm not you know I
don't know much about the hand gesture
sir but I I know enough about him to be
like oh that was the black power one
that's the one from the Olympics you
can't tell me at this point to get
arrested at a protest to stick your
[ __ ] hand up in the air you don't
feel like you're doing the Charleston
that doesn't feel a little dated you
know there's got to be something new
that you're doing like like that's like
doing a joke
take my wife please that's like the
[ __ ] protest version of that you only
mean like first she had the low five
then you had the high five then they
were bumping floor arms then they come
in and kind of do like that uh you know
it's like you deliberately miss and then
you should give four arms and elbows
kind of luck and then there's all these
elaborate [ __ ] handshakes like it
always goes to the next level but for
some reason with protesting they just
you know it's the timeless classic the
fists in the air I'm saying that needs
to be switched up I don't know what I
would go with you guys want to check in
on some feminist tweets one of my
favorite [ __ ] things to do let's see
what they're demanding today maybe
they're in a good mood today can you
imagine that imagine if you just went to
feminism they were like you know what
I'm kind of happy with America all right
feminists that's a probably good this is
just B people trashing feminism I don't
want to see that I want to Oh No
she's one of those feminists yeah this
is really just trashed feminist okay
this is a guy wearing this shirt of
course because he's woke feminism is the
radical notion that women are people to
some people it is what I love about
feminism is this really no clear-cut
definition it's just what it means to
the person it's kind of like what what
is art
why men's rights activist the shooter
according to his Facebook is a feminism
feminist sorry it's just gonna be
trashing out of Christ oh you know what
let me look this one up you got to get
the ones where they make it about
themselves that's my favorite Kevin
right how do you spell it
Kavanagh confirmed okay here we go
all right just an FYI FYI everyone
Supreme Court justices can be impeached
it rarely happens but it's absolutely
possible just keep in mind until oh I
don't know let's say mid-november all
right there's something about the
election when do I get my own handmaiden
that's how this works right all right
once again that's a little dramatic
don't you think yes probably I love this
is a good one I met three black people a
gay man a Hispanic man and more women
than men yesterday that support Kavanagh
identity politics is sexist and racist
don't be part of it identity politics is
gross don't be part of it I that's
always like convenient right you know I
think Obama stinks and I'm a Democrat
liberals help Kavanagh win by showing
how ridiculous they truly are
hell yeah at a Kavanagh come on man I
like the other ones oh it's some old guy
holding up a sign and there's some woman
dancing around him all right this is
just going off the rails I got it I got
it have I want this to be a [ __ ] a
legitimate segment the power structure
wasn't willing to risk not having a
majority of straight cisgender
conservative white men directing our
laws practices and policies into the
foreseeable future they would rather
have a sexual assault er than literally
anyone else yeah everybody sees it the
way that [ __ ] the way they [ __ ]
see it man
you know it's kind of weird way it's
with those things you don't the burden
of proof is way less because if that was
a trial that would have been like yeah
dude you can't be in there I think it
was him I don't really remember I yeah
yeah they'd be like all right yeah we
don't have time for this you got to come
back with [ __ ] evidence having said
that I still believe the woman though
just cuz she kept telling the [ __ ]
story over and over and over again I
don't know who the [ __ ] knows but some
of the [ __ ] that Cavanaugh was getting
like who doesn't have a bunch of [ __ ]
friends with stupid nicknames from high
school I was like [ __ ] Hedley squash
plank who's a Frenchie you're in high
school anyways plowing ahead
I'm keep missing all the goddamn racing
I got the [ __ ] f1 app and it just
keeps showing me I got the f1 TV and I
was watching what watching this race
from 1989 the Japanese f1 with that
Senna dude you know he's arguably the
best of all time and who the [ __ ] was he
up against and I forget his [ __ ] name
but it was phenomenal
I watched it almost right to the end
with Senna was coming back
driving like a lunatic and they actually
had the onboard cameras if you can watch
it like the cars back then sounds so
much more ferocious and dangerous and
then also when you just look at the lack
of safety it's just like they live
[ __ ] ahead is just you know I got
that halo and [ __ ] around you it
definitely seemed you know like the
death rate must have been way higher
obviously it was built I mean the guy
you're talking about it and I'm dying
but bill why don't you read some
advertising here now that you've
meandered and bombed with your [ __ ]
twitter feminism [ __ ] reading the
tweets there because you didn't look him
up why didn't you [ __ ] come on
there's got to be a good one in here
he's just not a likable looking guy this
Kavanagh I think that's when that's what
really hurts you you got to be likable
you know like Bill Clinton Bill Clinton
is likable the [ __ ] that that guy's
gotten busted for doing and women still
like it was [ __ ] it's unbelievable we
you know what this is this is just a
bunch of pro Cavanagh people throwing on
here and that's all it is we must vote
here's to the end of everything
r.i.p america Kavanagh confirmed I mean
that's a little dramatic we didn't just
hire this guy to become a [ __ ] Fuhrer
did we it's the end of everything all
right let me read the advertising carrot
buddy I know this is like brutally not
professional here okay oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh my bookie everybody sure watching
football's fund but it's more
entertaining when you have some action
on the games guys you've heard me talk
about this for weeks and some of you are
still on the sidelines whether you're an
expert or rookie you should be betting
at my bookie if you're the kind of guy
that likes to bet a little and win a lot
like playing the numbers on roulette you
can create a big parlor
pick three teams to win and it be hit
all three you could turn one hundred
dollars into six hundred dollars there's
no there's so much to bet on playoff
baseball hockey primetime fights and
more oh I do nothing I miss Conor
McGregor that point and then it spilled
out into the [ __ ] crowd but my bookie
is one of the is the one bet I know
you'll be happy with all year I
recommend these guys because I really
trust him
my bookie has been in business for years
and they got great online reviews and
their mobile site is easy to use if
you're on the sidelines now is the time
to get in the game my bookie will still
match your first dollar for dollar your
first deposit dollar for dollar but you
got to join now because they're pulling
that offer log on to my bookie right now
and double your money use promo code
Burr and you'll get your first deposit
matched 100% that's promo code burr you
play you win you get paid oh hymns
[Music]
sexual performance issues more common
than you think
over 25% of new IDI cases are guys under
40 I like how they never will say
erectile dysfunction can't get it up kid
40% of men by the age of 40 struggle
from not being able to get and maintain
an erection even the world's greatest
actor can't fake one why the guy's turn
to weird solutions or do nothing when
they can turn instead to medicines in
science I think he was just making fun
of people like drink soup out of rhino
horns for hims calm a one-stop shop for
hair loss skin care sexual wellness for
men thanks to science Edie can be
optional no waiting room no awkward
in-person doctor visits the lines save
hours by going to four hymns hymns hims
connects you with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat your
erectile dysfunction products are
shipped directly to your doula
well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help you
combat erectile dysfunction try hymns
for a month today for just five bucks
will get you started we're gonna give
you at the beginning of a [ __ ] for
just five
while supplies last see website for full
details this would cost hundreds if you
went to the doctor or a pharmacy go to
for hims com / / edy that's fo r hims
comm /b u RR e d for hims calm / / edy
all right oh look oh he got no oh it's
me undies a buddy did it do me undies me
undies my dick won't [ __ ] work to do
to be honest beyond easy even if I give
it a jerk it's laying it all down it
looks real sad she's got a leg spread
this is bad what if I rub my dick up
against these soft underwears maybe
it'll get in the game maybe get a pair
for [ __ ] price me undies you've heard
me obsess over my me undies and all the
amazing colors and prints they offer but
guys did you know that me undies also
makes the world's most comfortable
lounge pants and tees with fall finally
here now is perhaps the best time to put
these cozy essentials to the test the
lounge pants are made from the same
micro Modell modal fabric as their
undies let me tell you you'll be in fall
heaven when you cover your entire bottom
half your dick in your pools your taint
your vajayjay with fabric that is three
times softer than cotton the undies also
loves celebrating the fall season with
fun Halloween prints check out their
latest jack-o'-lantern prints and undies
socks and bra let's the best part when
you join the membership you can get all
this stuff Raun panties and undies
everything the undies makes for less
than anyone else special member pricing
is just one of the many perks of joining
the membership you're going to love
these undies but if you're not into it
the undies will do whatever they can to
get you into the right pair of Jesus boy
what Brighton [ __ ] another 12
paragraphs of coffee
anyways the undies has a great offer for
my listeners for any first-time
purchases when you purchase any me
undies you get 15% off and free shipping
there's this is a no-brainer get 15% off
your first pair or the most comfortable
undies you will ever put on to get your
15% off your first pair free shipping
and I'm satisfaction guarantee go to me
on DS dot-com / / that's me Eddie's calm
/ burn is this the last one thank God oh
look who's here policy genius you know
life insurance is really important but
one third of the people don't have it
that's because it's really hard to buy
you have to work out what you need then
do research to find the best quote and
hope you don't get swindled along the
way it's not a good way to shop for
anything so policy genius made the whole
process a lot simpler policy genius
compares quotes from the top life
insurance companies to the fine - find
the best policy for you it takes just
two minutes to get a quote and if you
don't know the first thing about
insurance they've got all the tools to
get you up to speed
learn the difference between term and
whole life insurance calculate how much
coverage you need and be sure you're
making the right decision in fact over
four million people have used policy
genius to shop for insurance policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy
they also compare disability insurance
home insurance and auto insurance if you
care about it they can cover it so
whether you know a lot about life
insurance or nothing at all start your
search at policy genius doc ROM it's
just two minutes you can compare quotes
and make an informed decision for you
and your loved ones policy genius the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance all right Jesus Christ that
was a long one
I missed the Conor McGregor my whole
podcast not because I've been traveling
so much as I everything that I missed I
missed MOC Marquez when his [ __ ]
seventh MotoGP race of the year he's
running away with the title once again
I'm still trying to figure out how to
watch f1 races legally on the internet I
signed up for something I paid for it
that f1 TV now watch it [ __ ] from
[ __ ] 1989 I saw that the Russian guy
what are the his names kibbles and bits
there he with his big furry hat he beat
the Burger King guy there Conor McGregor
um which is gonna set up a great rematch
if we you know something will be great
if they didn't [ __ ] add that stupid
fight in the end that was really dumb
you know I don't understand like when
those bras break out there's like 90% of
people are going to break it up and then
there's always that one lunatic that
just comes running in
you know flies it he just jumps in and
tries to punch somebody say what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you anyways here are
some of my upcoming dates everybody I'm
gonna be in Saginaw Michigan at the
dowel Event Center Center this Friday
October 12th and then the next day I'm
going to the Wolverines first the
[ __ ] Wisconsin Badgers I'm gonna be
in Baltimore Maryland at the Modell
Modell lyric oh my god is this some
biondi's gig October 18th the early
shows sold out late show tickets still
available
Atlantic City in New Jersey Borgata
Resort October 19th for two shows I was
supposed to they added another show in
the 20th but we're gonna move that one
because that's my it's my five-year
wedding anniversary that weekend so I
got to be home
ain't gonna be good five-year wood right
I gotta get her something made out of
wood I'm gonna Whittle something October
26 like Phoenix Arizona I'm at the
Comerica theater doing the evening show
there I also I'm gonna do the goddamn
Comedy Jam and my podcast and then I got
Madison Square Garden on November 7th
and then I end my year November 8th
through the 10th at the Chicago theater
8 9 10 8 9 10 3 days there ok three days
at the unbelievable Chicago theater and
[Music]
and that's it and then the rest of the
year I'm [ __ ] off but it's already
filling up with [ __ ] it has always
some sort of [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
alright let's let's read some of the
questions here for this week oh yeah you
know they say sober October
which I jumped in too late because I I
drank the first day then I didn't drink
any other days except last night I had a
few you know I'm in Boston what am I
supposed to do
so I've drank two - wata what's today
what's today the 8th all right so I'm
six and two I'm back on the wagon here
we go and I was saying well you know be
great the you know sober October makes
you not want to drinking be great they
could come up with a rhyme for November
so somebody came up with no bender
November doesn't really rhyme but it's
close enough he said yo Billy TD GAD and
crushed on the parquet floors Friday
thank you he said no booze in November
is called no bender November in case you
can't think of a way to rhyme you dumb
genius well it doesn't really were on ok
and there's a word for that when there's
two things that they sound like they
rhyme but they don't it's called
hyperbole when I forget what it's called
it's called a run-on sentence and I
[ __ ] never then [ __ ] those stupid
terms you an English class two words
that rhyme but don't terminology what do
you call two words that rot no no no no
I didn't I didn't ask her right god damn
it
two words that sound like they rhyme but
they don't come on give it to me what
does it call the word sound like they
rhyme but don't all right half a rhyme I
thought they had a bigger term for that
soliloquy I don't know anyways let's get
back to this [ __ ] [ __ ] all right
toilet paper versus of fancy toilet hey
freckles the seat is better for the
environment because thousands and
thousands of liters of water and
kilowatts of power go into the
production of toilet paper
thanks you dumb [ __ ] okay well
about having to then have an electric
toilet seat what about all the extra
water you're going to be using hosing
off your [ __ ] you know I mean they
both it's like driving a Tesla okay so
it doesn't use any gas but what happens
you throw out that giant battery
underneath the car although I'm totally
for those cars and electric power they
don't because even if it pollutes the
environment just as much at least we'll
be out of the Middle East you know
that's how you solve that problem we
just convert to solar power and we all
drive quiet electric cars you know
they're a [ __ ] one-trick pony over
there in the Middle East they don't
produce any cars than anybody wants you
know cuisine they got cuisine and they
got oil that cuisines delicious our cars
love their oil but you know if you put
that out to put them out of business
there you go then they don't want money
to fund any sort of terrorist groups and
then we leave them the [ __ ] alone
and then they go back to just being mad
at each other done I'll see you declare
victory go home all right make a
smoothie broccoli sprouts in your
smoothie Guerra Billy bison but I'm
really into fitness and eating healthy
and all that all right to that point you
may want to consider researching the
benefits of broccoli sprouts they
contain a lots of anti-cancer properties
and the research is new with lots of
tests to back it up I want you to live
forever thanks - go [ __ ] yourself all
right so what am I supposed to look this
up broccoli sprouts no this just
straight up broccoli what stem steamed
broccoli in a sprout broccoli sprouts
cancer all right let's see what they say
here a compound of broccoli sprouts may
not only help prevent cancer but also
treated well Jesus Christ that's about
it may
stuffer laughing is founded vegetables
such as kale cauliflower and cabbage and
in particular high concentrations in
young broccoli sprouts
oh Jesus Christ it's now I gotta be I
got to eat those things you're gonna
freeze them all right well you know I
looked it up it said they do that so now
I believe it I eat enough broccoli
sprouts a little [ __ ] knows all right
here we go I'll definitely do it you
know all right
Art Deco bars hey there freckles you
mentioned looking into an art deco bar
check this one out it comes inside an 80
million dollar airplane pretty sweet
drop a few of those Netflix there let me
see this [ __ ] thing an art deco bar
in a plane that's not in a plane what
private business aircraft manager and
Embraer executive Jeff have created a
new luxury jet dubbed the Manhattan
which takes passengers back to the 1920s
with its Art Deco designs isn't it
enough that you're flying private yeah
I'd love a private jet but what is the
theme created by the company's vice
president of interior design Jade Viva
and former Disney Imagineer imogen ear
Eddie Soto the jet will t sound Shady
Eddie Soto J Bieber you'll try to [ __ ]
your girlfriend Eddie so totally Shady
the jet will make you feel as though
you're stepping back in time and it's
with its rich mahogany wood panels brass
and gold trimmings and vibrant jewel
tones it's just sounds like it's going
to take up a lot of fuel to get this
thing off the ground beaver was inspired
by the Art Deco interior designs of the
SS Normandy French ocean liner identity
of the SS
in German Psychopaths sir I used the
Nazis Nazi Germany to inspire this this
bill somebody explained to me how the
[ __ ] you can never fly private and make
any money I will never understand that
you know it cost an absolute fortune and
you can't even write it off you like if
you spend like 20 grand on a [ __ ]
private plane ticket like the
government's only well it's like what
you could have flown first class for 15
out of bucks two grand
you're the dumbass that spent another
than 18 grand that's on you that's the
way it might count explain it to me
alright [ __ ] talking people dear Billy
Justice what's the deal with okay so
what's the deal with [ __ ] talkers
getting mad when other people talk [ __ ]
all of my beef comes from hypocrites
these days I keep hearing people
comedians as well get mad at people who
who make fun of them the same people who
make a living doing the same I need some
examples here this yeah I mean I don't
agree with that if you go around making
fun of people then you shouldn't get mad
at people making fun of you right
meaning like hecklers I don't mind
hecklers you know I don't mind these
[ __ ] people that write mean [ __ ] to
me on Twitter it's annoying but I mean I
just accept it I try to I try to rise
above it the same people will make a
living doing the same thing the same
people who never think for a minute
about what they're saying flip the [ __ ]
out when someone trashes them it's
something I yell at too no one in my car
on the way home from work on a daily
basis this is his quote you [ __ ]
how can you expect to be treated like
this when you yourself are doing the
same thing it's the Golden Rule right
out the window it's the law of nature
right out the window
bill I'm losing my mind anyways I was
wondering how you deal with these people
do you yell at everyone you know do you
lose your friends and colleagues I'm
sure you've had a celebrity friend
complain about something they have done
themselves a million times what would
you say to that
um well listen if you're gonna talk
about hypocritical behavior I'm the
[ __ ] king of that and I've been
guilty of that trashing people on stage
then getting upset if someone was a dick
to me everybody everybody's like that
everybody's got claws so I don't know
we'll really know what you're asking me
but like I do find it funny with some of
these people who are like in
entertainment who are you know pro-women
advancement and all that which why
wouldn't you be but then the way they go
they go about it is they're they say all
this sexist [ __ ] about guys these you
know big sweeping generalizations and
all that it's like you literally sound
like what you're fighting right now
they're like oh shut up you're a white
guy it's like yeah yeah a white guy who
would know more about that then then a
white guy you sound like a white guy
maybe that's the way you try to convey
it to them because then you kind of [ __ ]
on yourself you sound like a white man
that is not a compliment you know what I
mean why do I think this audio is gonna
be played at a Klan meeting this is
where the white man is right now he
thinks to sound like himself it is not a
compliment it all went off the rails
with first freeing the slaves second yo
MTV raps and then Obama yeah I would
just say that like some of the [ __ ] like
I thought a lot of the ways that people
were just talking about Kavanagh was
like it's astoundingly like you don't
hear that you're doing what you're doing
you're against racism and all of that
[ __ ] like you can't say you're being
racist against the white guy because
your thoughts don't affect but it's
basically if you were in power that guy
would be [ __ ] like a white guy you
just never heard the word no every door
just flew open you know that that
cartoon version of being a white dude I
don't know I just thought so much if it
was about
they just built this host story behind
this guy
I guess that's identity politics like oh
he went to Yale he's a white guy he was
you know he played sports okay
he's a date rapist all the doors flew
open his dad was a judge he never went
to jail a little blood whatever the [ __ ]
they're talking about it's just gonna
like about a little evidence yeah all
right boyfriend being Shady
hey I didn't even answer this guy's
question what do I say those people you
know if I'm in a zone I don't say
anything if I'm in a bad place I'll let
it ruin my morning and I'm like you and
I like I remember when Harvey Weinstein
first got busted and then Fox News was
going this is what Hollywood is like and
I just remember yelling and your Network
Bill O'Reilly what about all these other
than you [ __ ] what do you have main
guys over there
I mean I don't know me TV is where it's
at I'm telling you all right boyfriend
being Shady
hey Billy no buns no my man and I have
been together for six years but this
past year he's become really close to
this lady from work that's not good they
spent a lot of time together going to
bars parties and work obviously I don't
go out with them because I don't like to
drink and have anxiety he'll make me
feel like I'm crazy for getting upset
but if the situation was switched and I
was going out drinking and dancing with
another man he'd be pissed too yeah yeah
exactly exactly he's going out drinking
and dancing with another woman I think
you're welling you're right to be like
yes so then I mean the next logical step
is you get a finger blaster here I mean
what's going on here anyway so what's
your opinion on this do I need to chill
out and if so how lol thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself no you need to validate what
you're thinking this is [ __ ]
Vic don't you're out drinking and
dancing with another woman I mean I
don't think you know the only thing that
could say that is if you don't go out if
you don't hang out and you have anxiety
I don't know what the anxiety is about
but like you know if this guy likes to
go out and you don't like to go out at
all maybe you guys aren't right for each
other
or maybe you guys find some [ __ ] that
you both like you know yeah I mean
that's that's not a good situation so I
would I would tell the person wait what
you're thinking I don't think you're
being wrong and I think that is shady
behavior all right
let's just make [ __ ] do I know what the
[ __ ] do I know
all right what do we got here this is
the last question I got twelve minutes
left I swear to God if I don't have my
microphone in my [ __ ] headphones
it's literally looks like kryptonite all
right first breakup hey you freckled
[ __ ] versus the [ __ ] relationship
goes down the tubes and they come at me
all hostile I'll make this quick I just
wanted to tell someone and honestly
honestly before I talked my to my
parents I know you're dyslexic like me
so I'll use basic words well I
appreciate that
I'm a senior in high school I'm on the
varsity wrestling and run disc and run
distance track my free time has only
consisted of homework and Netflix
parenthesis efforts of families my
favorite show nice did you guys see how
he announced that the great Ben Sivan
will be on the will be on season three
all right No season two no season three
yeah season three champion [ __ ]
confused myself anyways he said I'm a
senior in high school ba ba ba ba
well that was like ten months ago I had
never dated a girl ever but I had a
crush on this girl for like a full year
she runs cross-country in his way
smarter than I will ever be
all right great put her up on a pedestal
see how that works she's a year younger
than me but we eventually started
talking because when the boys and girls
varsity teams would hang out we both
would be there eventually she became all
that I thought about I literally could
not focus on school running etc we
talked almost every night over text
and we're together every time I went out
with the team we went to homecoming my
first time together a few weeks ago and
I had my first kiss there Jesus Christ
it sounds like a [ __ ] perfect story
after that night we really didn't talk
over text that much we don't have any
classes together and practice is not a
good time to hang out anyway about a
week ago she texted me and said she
didn't see a future of us being more
than friends
I told her what I felt I just said
that's fair and all I want is for her to
be happy which is true but I thought I
would be able to brush that [ __ ] off
like it was nothing but I'm writing this
email for no reason so that obviously
didn't happen should I have fought
harder to keep us together just move on
I'd never been in a relationship and I
don't know what to do anymore
would appreciate your advice as always
go [ __ ] yourself you sound like a funny
kid man I think you can get yourself you
know I think you'll be fine
just keep using humor cry it out of you
yeah you [ __ ] you you fell hard for
this person and then they sent you
packing and then you're like what is
there something wrong with me and it's
like no there isn't
you're just not right it's not like she
broke up with you for a specific thing
you know you're torturing animals and I
just don't like that about you she just
said we're not right she didn't feel the
spark the way you did that's what
happens and she did you a favor so the
best thing is you didn't yell at her and
you're still kind of friendly with her
so what I would do is I would just
[ __ ] yeah but don't brush it off if
you have to like brush something off
that means you're trying to trick
yourself that you don't give a [ __ ] you
do give a [ __ ] and just sort of exist in
giving a [ __ ] about it talk it out with
people but I would leave her alone but
be friendly what'd they say hey what's
up and blah blah blah and you know and
you young you still in high school do
you got it you got a you got a zillion
at bat so what's your first [ __ ] in a
bet you know what are you gonna do so I
wouldn't I wouldn't take it
that hard but it's normal that if you
like somebody and they break up with you
for you to feel bad alright if you could
have just brushed it off like it was no
big deal then that would mean that you
didn't like or that you were like a
sociopath and then what that would lead
you to torturing animals and eventually
work your way up to the ultimate prey
being a human being walking out of a
7-eleven unsuspectingly so that's it is
that gonna be the podcast 53 minutes I'm
contractually obligated to do another
six and a half minutes here right
so anyways I've been pretty good on my
diet breakfast I've been better than
anything else but just coming back here
I've been trying to avoid all the old
haunts that I go to but it's been it's
been difficult I've been trying to do
this smoothies in the morning but you
know I'm staying with some relatives and
they've just been you know just like Oh
so-and-so's in town let's make pancakes
right what are you gonna say no actually
no could I get some Greek yogurt with
some berries and some chia seeds
whatever the [ __ ] you call those things
I mean that's acceptable on the west
coast you do that out here everybody
starts looking at you like hey dude you
know don't forget what he came from now
you're an East Coast guy okay you die of
a heart attack in your fifties or
sixties then you know that's how it
works so get over here sit down and eat
this [ __ ] that's gonna make you want to
take a nap that's basically it right
well I'm hoping uh
I'm hoping I can jump right back I'm
gonna jump right back on the diet when I
get out there I'm doing the best I can i
if I could get a [ __ ] shower today
then I would I would be I'd be fine I
just have to get on the other side of
this to be honest with you I get to the
other side of the [ __ ] Chicago
theater gig and once I do that then I
feel I can just cruise for the rest of
the year I'm gonna do my Eastern
European tour and then some another
little run I think next year how we're
gonna do is every six
weeks I'm gonna go overseas and knock
something out hopefully get some
Australia dates in that type of [ __ ]
that is the game plan and somewhere in
there to shoot a special I don't know
where a win yet but um I don't know it's
feeling like it's feeling like it's
[ __ ] ready you know and I've been
throwing in all these extra lines and
people been really laughing and all of
it just goes in the complete opposite
direction of all of this [ __ ] that's
kind of been going on out there which I
don't know means it's either gonna be a
really good special or I'm just gonna
get [ __ ] trashed well like this just
sounds like a whining white male pining
for the way things used to be but
they're the baby thing you know when
they do that [ __ ] [ __ ] it's just like
no I'm a contrarian that's all it is
so evidently a star is born which stars
a Dave Chappelle Andrew Dice Clay I
think there's one other comedian in
there too I didn't see it my wife saw it
neva dentally loved it to the point that
she was crying like a loved one died
she's like you got to come out we have
to see that movie and I was like is it
like a dirty dancing type of movie cuz I
just don't see myself maybe it was a
good thing that you saw it by yourself
and I guess she's like Bradley Cooper's
entities [ __ ] unbelievable he brought
all the music he's so talented and I was
like I love Bradley Cooper right and
she's like Lady Gaga's in it I was like
oh she's like what's the matter guys you
don't remember that a long time ago when
I went to the Lady Gaga concert with you
it was the day the Patriots got crushed
by the Ravens in the playoffs so I'd
already had like six beers you remember
that and evidently I said Jesus [ __ ]
Christ in the middle of the concert I
finally said it once she said he said it
like four times we got in this big
[ __ ] fight
not really she was just mad at me saying
that I ruined the experience for us so
like ever since then whenever she goes
to one of these big shows like she
doesn't she doesn't ask me to go anymore
[Laughter]
which is funny but now that I said it
out loud is a little sad I think I
should be able to sit through no I liked
Lady Gaga when she was singing but it
just kept it just was like this [ __ ]
I don't know what it was it was like
this self-help program I felt more than
a concert and they just kept [ __ ]
talking about how they didn't give a
file give a [ __ ] you give a [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] it's just like get on with
not giving a [ __ ] who stands around
talking about how they don't give a [ __ ]
jesus [ __ ] christ I mean that's
basically what it was like that was
probably only like 20% of it the other
80% was that my team lost and they
[ __ ] playoffs so it's probably a good
thing I don't know yeah I'll be honest
with you I don't I don't know I don't
know if I can sit through a movie that
has people singing in it and that has
nothing to do with the people that are
singing it has to do with me I just
don't know what it is like I I can watch
the dumbest [ __ ] ever like somebody is a
hundred people with machine guns
shooting at the guy and somehow the guy
doesn't die like that to me for some
reason it's less ridiculous than
watching two people sitting across from
each other talking and all of a sudden
one of them starts singing and nobody's
like looking like to burn a restaurant
can you stop [ __ ] sing and just just
say what you have to say you weird me
out here like no no that moment never
happens in a musical you know what's
funny as I don't know what that movies
about I should go see it because I'm I I
don't know I watched the same [ __ ]
movie over and over again it's just it
has a different title so you know I'm
gonna broad memory you know [ __ ] it I'm
gonna go
that movie I'll go see it because Dyson
Chappelle are in it right now God if I
go there my wife is crying and I have to
like comfort her and all that [ __ ] Jesus
Christ it's just like I thought we were
gonna throw we having a good time
look at you you're [ __ ] crying and
now we're walking in public and
everybody's looking at me like I just
said something mean to you and I got a
big no no no she just saw a star was
born it was really good
that's why she has an expression on her
face like something really bad just
happened was that dirty dancin weird or
word of bull you know I don't know
there's people who watch Top Gun and
they like the airplanes and then there's
other people that watch it and they like
the kiss between Tom Cruise and Keli
McGinness me I just like the volleyball
game alright I'm [ __ ] with you
alright thanks Alissa podcast thank you
to everybody who came out to Springfield
Boston and Bridgeport Connecticut my
mind is blown that I was able to play in
those venues there was it didn't even
make sense I felt like a [ __ ] cartoon
character I ever never never even
thought I could ever do would ever do
something like that so thank you so much
and everybody Saginaw Michigan
you know it's [ __ ] amazing most
Saginaw Nishant Michigan my great
grandfather and grandmother had a house
in Saginaw Michigan and I'm gonna drive
and take a picture of it for some of my
relatives because they want to see if
it's still the same thing but they lived
there like a [ __ ] hundred years ago
see you never know probably has solar
panels on it
so everybody knocked it down and made a
McMansion the [ __ ] hot tub and [ __ ]
there who knows but I'm really looking
forward to because I've never performed
in Saginaw Michigan so we're all
bringing our a-game me virzi bartnick
Saginaw Michigan the next day we're
going to the big house so if they're at
the tailgate alright look for two bald
guys in one [ __ ] giant
cam neely looking guy will be hammered
we'll see you there alright check in on
you on Thursday